The bloodstream is an extremely
dramatic place. It links all your
organs together, provides nutrients,
proteins, and oxygen. About 60% of the
five liters of blood in your body is a
fluid called plasma. The rest is cells,
and it's all moving at three to four
miles per hour. These cells transform
into fierce warriors whenever an
invader is detected. Introducing your
body's supporters and defenders: the
cells of the blood.
Our journey begins in the bone marrow,
the spongy tissue inside our bones
where the blood cells are born. They
escape through little vessels that
connect the bones to the rest of the
bloodstream. There are three main types
of cells in the blood, each with a
specialized role: platelets, red blood
cells and white blood cells. Let's take
a closer look. First up, we have
platelets, tiny little helpers that
flow through the bloodstream, not doing
a whole lot. But when a vessel gets
damaged, either from a chemical
imbalance in the surrounding area or
from physical damage like a cut,
platelets get a signal that it's their
time to shine. They rush to the site of
damage and stick together, extending
little tentacles to patch up any holes
in the vessel, forming a clot and
stopping more damage. Next up, our red
blood cells, also called erythrocytes.
They're the most abundant blood cell.
In every cubic millimeter of blood you
can find around five million red blood
cells. Their job is to pick up oxygen
from the lungs, stored in little red
packages called hemoglobin that make
the blood red. Then they truck it to
the rest of the body so your organs can
use it to make energy from sugar and
fat. They're so dedicated to this job
that they don't even have nuclei. Their
dented hockey puck shape makes more
room for hemoglobin. After they drop
off their oxygen, they have to return
to the lungs to grab more and start the
process all over again. The most
complicated cells of the blood are the
white blood cells, a.k.a., leukocytes.
An important part of the body's immune
system, they're a squadron of elite
agents that identify and hunt down
threats to the body, like viruses and
bacteria. They can be divided by their
specialized roles. Some cells notice
when something's off and sound the
alarm. Others are in charge of directly
fighting the threat. These cells can
recognize, remember and hunt down virus
infected cells, mutated tumor cells,
you name it. And those are the cells of
the blood.